Hello everyone.
As we get into the final days of 2017
I'd like to take the opportunity to
encourage you guys to share your
comments, questions, concerns,
suggestions and all that sort of thing.
As we look toward the new year,
a problem a lot of youtube channels have
I noticed is that they don't respond to
their audiences and I
value your guys' input.
I read all your comments and I take would
you guys say into consideration as a
way to improve my channel and so I
wanted to do this and then make a video
sometime early January responding to
what you guys have said. Two big things.
I get, for example, one, I
talked too quickly and too,
I sound too monotonous.
Sometimes.
Those are things which I have been trying
to improve on and I like to say that I
think I've gotten better since the
spring and summer of this year. Secondly,
I want to reiterate,
I do not mind if you guys
correct or criticize me
because fire of learning holds
truthful,
factual on biased genuine information
as a top priority because I honestly
believe that that kind of information
deserves a safe haven and this kind of
world and I know that there are plenty
of you out there that share the same
frustration and I would rather have
a dumb mistake called out then help
perpetuate something that is wrong just
so that I can look like I have a giant
perfect,
admirable brain and I appreciate that
you guys have corrected me and I've tried
to give you credit and the comments of
videos where I have made an error not to
spend too much time on this point,
but I would add that saying I'm wrong
or that my video was bad without
explaining why just comes off as pompous
ship posting part of my French and I
can't really do much with it.
I have more videos coming before the
end of 2017 and the coming year I have
plans. I admit I work
spontaneously and wing a lot,
but I do have some plans.
There was more science I want to cover,
probably going to try to do overviews of
the histories of a couple other nations
and peoples like I did with
the Vikings and England.
I know you guys like the top 10 tips
videos and I'm going to cover some new
topics too and that's another thing too.
I am always interested in hearing from
you guys what topics you guys want me to
make videos on.
So I just wanted to make
a video explaining where
fire of learning is at and
encouraged this opportunity for
you guys to give your input.
Thank you all for watching over
the past two and a half years.
Thank you for getting fire of loading two,
almost three and a half
thousand subscribers. Now.
Welcome to all of you who are new,
be on the lookout for new content.
I have coming out.
I have a busy schedule often,
but I do make an effort to keep videos
coming. Happy holidays to everyone.
Happy New Year and thank
you all again for watching.